so I was on set for the second season of
Comedy Central's corporate and usually
when I'm working I like to read during
my downtime set the little annoying
overachiever inside of me is like I'm
gettin paid to read I'm gonna pay to
learn it's just like college just
without accumulating hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt and a
flailing job market economy fix your
education system America but anyway I
like to binge authors or genres and at
this time I was binging relationship
self-help books shut up don't scroll
down to the comments right now and the
book I was reading was called how to be
an adult in relationships and trust me I
know everyone who saw me reading it was
like judgment judgment Oh judge man
finish her judge judge away you know we
never learned how to be in relationship
except by actually being in them and you
would read a book about surgery before
attempting surgery wouldn't you
but one of my posters actually saw what
I was reading and we bonded over her
mutual love of what is that oh yes you
guessed it therapy and personal
development and she said you know I went
to couples therapy years ago with my
wife and they gave us really good advice
they said if you're ever gonna fight
with anyone
ask yourself how old do I feel right now
it all made sense I mean if you're in
therapy you probably know that your
therapist always brings it back to your
old wounds from childhood right you
always roll your eyes because you're so
tired of freaking talking about the
anxious attachment style you form with
your parents but this question really
works cuz when I thought about it there
are several instances where it's like
when I fought with my best friend Kat
about feeling left out I felt like I was
13 and my friends had ditched me at the
mall when I fought with my partner about
being ignored inside I felt like I was
like nine years old and struggling for
my father's attention against my
siblings so whenever I ask myself that
question I would always find out what
was really going on because I could
trace it back to time when I was
rejected or bullied his kid then I could
just explain those core feelings to her
and we would work at him and I thought
this was just such great advice you know
I mean my brother and I were even
talking about how ridiculous it is that
were not equipped to deal with
relationships I know why don't they
teach this shit in school like there
should be classes on how to manage your
emotions how to communicate in
relationships and just generally how to
sort out your stuff I couldn't agree
more like we need to remember the
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell I couldn't agree more
like oh no wait you're doing great
you're doing great
it's great acting great acting and just
generally how to sort out your stuff I
couldn't agree more I'll wait
no let's always remember them vitac
Andreea is the powerhouse of the cell
[Music]
never forget the nucleus I'm Anna Akana
stay right here for an animated ad by
Bethany Radloff awesome Gotham what
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video Squarespace has beautiful
award-winning templates and an
all-in-one platform so you never have to
install patches or upgrades ever they
offer a unique and simple setup
experience if you need a domain and
24-hour customer service if you have a
question at 3:00 a.m. with Squarespace
you can build any kind of website
whether you're a couple therapists a
single looking for love or just a couple
that wants to brag about how you found
the one go to squarespace.com slash ana
to start your free trial today and use
the offer code ana for 10% off at
checkout
[Music]